thank you Karen good morning to
everybody I don't know if I can
entertain you but at least I I will
start by paraphrasing a famous Austrian
actor who became known worldwide beside
others by saying I will be back and I
can say I am happy to be back I see so
many friends and familiar faces here
today not now because I'm away the light
is very strong so I can't see you but I
have already seen some of you outside
and it's a great pleasure for me and
also a great opportunity to discuss
smart regions and what has happened
since its introduction smart
specialization it was something which
was not welcomed by everybody but I
think in the meantime the success is is
clear and I think it was good that six
years ago we really insisted to
introduce smart specialization for
cohesion policy and therefore in a way
mayor say with all modesty it's a kind
of spiritual child of mine at the end of
the previous programming period it was
clear that we needed a new approach to
unlock regional coasts potential at the
end of the previous mff to raise the
game for investment in innovation for
activity and competitiveness we worked
hard with many of you here which are
here today already
to make this possible and standing here
before you six years on I can tell you
that we can all be proud for designing
and introducing smart specialization
because it has in the meantime proven
it's worth today it's an accepted norm
that investment funds alone are not
enough and that each region needs a plan
the strategy and that this can only be
done in a bottom-up manner this gave
birth to the interpreter in the
Praetorian maternal discovery process a
collaborative effort including private
sector and academic community building
on each other's strengths six years on
the results are clear as it was already
set by Karen we have 180 smart
specialization strategies in the current
programming period leading to 18,000 or
docked innovations that are now new to
the market I think this is quite
remarkable and it's also thanks to all
your personal efforts whether you are
researchers businesspeople or public
administrators you are the ones doing
the work on the ground you are the ones
rising to the challenge day-in day-out
dear friends digitalization and new
technologies will profoundly change the
way we live and work these changes bring
new opportunities they are transforming
areas such health mobility industry and
science they are the key to Europe's
future competitiveness and growth at the
same time digitalization brings risks
the risk of widening digital skills gap
the risk of deepening social and
regional divides within Europe do this
we must add climate change and the
transition to a low-carbon economy again
this brings benefits and opportunities
in the long term but in the short term
they are adjustment costs and these
costs may concentrate in specific areas
so there are opportunities ahead but
first we must ensure that no region is
left behind I'm thinking in particular
of industrial transition regions and of
catching-up regions it's no coincidence
that these are the subjects of our first
two parallel sessions today these
regions face specific challenge
for example while smart specialization
is relevant to all regions less
developed regions require specific
attention with regard to human capital
and skills development in addition
innovation actors in less developed
regions of not well connected not well
connected to the wider research and
innovation community not well connected
to global value change this problems
require targeted solution for example in
the port card passkey a region of Poland
the problem identified was a weak link
between business and university a
professionally as liaison was
established between business and science
while the port Kapowski center for
innovation this has increased the
commercialization of IND work in the
region it has also led to bottle up a
physical space for learning and
experimenting with various production
technologies by students and young
scientists this brings me to my second
principle we need more experimentation
Europe's great strengths is its
diversity and the willingness of actors
at national regional and city level to
test new approaches win the Union
Commission has harnessing the power of
this diversity and this willingness we
have launched a number of pilot actions
to test new approaches one such test is
the pilot action on regions in
industrial transition this started at
the end of 2017
we are helping ten regions and two
member states undergoing industrial
transition we are encouraging
experiments in finding the strengths and
potentials as they embrace innovation in
the face of decarbonization and
digitization this brings me to my third
point
we need more intelligent cooperation and
joint investments we need more value
change that cause borders we need more
opportunities for companies to scale up
the ideas and to get the benefits from a
connected global economy our companies
should be going global so in the last
few years we have been promoting
stronger strategic interracial
cooperation we have been promoting
linkages between regional ecosystems we
have been promoting investment pipelines
across borders and new you value chains
we are doing this through 25 active
partnerships on the smart specialization
platform in three somatic areas
industrial modernization aqua food and
energy more than 100 regions are already
involved
the partnership covers an exciting range
of themes including innovative
investments in petals 3d printing
cybersecurity the circular economy
high-tech farming renewable energy and
energy efficient building and some of
them you can see in the exhibition
outside in the new program period this
approach will be scaled up and
mainstreamed this underlines our
commitment to value change and smart
specialization which costs borders it
also underlines our commitment to the
future dear friends ladies and gentlemen
in conclusion our digital green and
smart future is exciting and
undiscovered area full of new
possibilities and new opportunities and
our region's need to become smart to
harness all these opportunities so
please save a place for me at your
conference this topic will always be
close to my heart and maybe one day I
will be back again
then really as in very interested
pension ists thank you very much
[Applause]